what does not disappear in all this is
the eye as universal who's seeing is
neither seeing of the tree nor of this
house but it is a simple singing which
though mediated by the negation of this
house and so on it is all the same
simple and and different to whatever
happens in it to the house to the tree
and so forth
the is merely universal like now here or
this in general I do indeed mean a
single eye but I can say no more say
what I mean in the case of eye than I
can in the case of now and here when I
say to this here this now or a single
item I am saying all this is hears now's
all single items similarly when I say I
this singular eye I say in general all
is everyone is what I say everyone is I
this singular eye when science is faced
with the demand as if as it were an acid
test it could not pass that it should to
do is construct find out priori or
however it is put something call this
thing or this one a man it is reasonable
that the demand should say which this
thing or which this particular man has
met but it is impossible to say this
in section 92 we're going to see a
similar dialectic played out within the
subject or in terms of subjects those
who are engaging in sense perception and
as we've seen earlier with the objects
of sense perception we're going to see
the same movement to a universal and
towards a kind of problematic that that
then introduces for us so let's go back
to where we left off with section 101 we
have one eye over here that's seeing a
tree sense perception for it is it's
seeing its activity of seeing the tree
remember it is what has fixed that tree
as being what sense perception is about
on the other hand there's another eye
over there that's seeing the house and
now notice that they can actually
communicate with each other they are
they are capable of entering into
relation and of seeing that no sense
perception is not just confined to the
activity of this one eye there's other
eyes out there so what can we do to
overcome this well we can talk about an
eye in general we can move to a
universal with this why do we do that
because we're human beings because we
actually do share a lot in common
because we're both spirit or subject or
however you want to talk about it so he
says what doesn't disappear in all this
is the eye as universal the eye in
general who's seeing is neither a seeing
of the tree nor of this house but a
simple see so what we have going on here
is a negation and we also have a
negation here a mediation which doesn't
say no I over there you're not seeing
the house it just says what what the eye
as universal is seeing is not the house
is not they the tree it's it's just
whatever happens to be seen so once
again we see the same structure of the
universal as both negating and B
what its particulars are and doing so by
way of mediation that's what it means
for something to be a universal for for
Hegel so he says it's all the same
simple and indifferent to whatever
happens in it to the house to the tree
etc the eye is merely universal like now
here or this in general here's where we
get to a really important point Hegel
says that I do intend I do - I do want
or have in mind a particular a single
eye so what we have here is singularity
or particulate particularity versus
universality what is meant versus what
can be said what can be expressed
linguistically so I have in mind this I
that that is me or maybe if I'm gonna
get humble it's the other eye I care
more about that anything for Hegel
that's not usually the case so I want to
know about this eye that I am in the
sense perception perception that I'm
having and I know what it is like vanish
into this this eye in general or the
universal eye but I can't quite keep
that from happening because I can't
express at least not at this stage what
it means for me to be that I he says I
can no more say what I mean in the case
of I then I can in the case of now and
here with with now in here we can talk
about well I mean day I mean night I
mean horse I mean kite I mean you know
whatever you want but I couldn't quite
explain to myself what I mean by now in
general or here in general and what the
relationship was between the now that I
have that I want to hold fast and now we
might say written in capital letters
it's the same thing with the self with
the the I the individual says when I say
this here this now we're a single item
when I try to make it
particular when I try to make it
determinate I invert you the fact that
I'm saying it
I'm already translating it into
universal terms so by saying this here
I'm already saying here in general so he
says similarly when I say I this
singular I I say in general all eyes
everyone is what I say everyone is I
this singular I there is no absolute
priority of the individual I that I am
over other eyes you might say that one
manifestation of that is the fact that I
don't have the monopoly on the word I
and it's kind of interesting you think
about it Hegel doesn't go into this here
but it's worth thinking about this
linguistically because this might
actually help you understand what he's
trying to say if the word I only meant
this I then it couldn't actually mean I
let me sound a little paradoxical let me
say it one more time but let me a
substitute another word if I were to say
goobidy goobidy goobidy to myself and
mean what i mean by saying i and insist
that only this is goobidy goobidy
goobidy watching are that then what
happens to them that weird nonsense
thing that I've made up it is just a
nonsense thing what happens if I let's
take another example what happens if I
say only I am Greg there's no other Greg
no you know there's not only a lot there
Greg's because also a whole bunch of
other Greg Sandler's you know there's
one who's a photographer there's you
know all sorts of other ones I am and
they track them all down but there's a
whole ton of them but let's say I was
crazy enough to say Greg Sadler refers
only to this object and only to this
object and nobody else shall ever use
that location again that it would
quickly mean just a proper name and it
wouldn't signify me you wouldn't signify
it is to be a subject and it would
probably pass on a currency pretty
quickly so by being I I'm already sort
of losing myself in the other eyes and
in the universal eye and the same thing
is happening to all those other poor
eyes as well he says when I say I I say
in general all eyes everyone is what I
say everyone is I the singular eye
because you can say eye to me just as
much as I can say it to you when silence
he says his face with the demand as if
it were an acid test that could not be
yes that it should deduce construct find
out priori so we're talking about
abstract processes here right or however
it is put something called this thing or
this one man when it has to turn to
singularity or particularity it has one
hell of a time doesn't it he says it's
reasonable that the demand should say
which this thing if you're going to talk
about individuality or singularity or
particularly you can't do that in purely
general terms you have to be able to
somehow gesture or point out or give
some sort of indications what's going to
supply that for us that's one of the
questions that hasn't been answered at
this point so what we're left with is a
kind of diffusion of the the eye that is
the one perceiving into the general eye
since certainty thus comes to know by
experience that its essence is neither
in the object nor in the eye and that
its immediacy is neither an immediacy of
the one nor the other
for in both what I mean is rather
something on essential and the object
and the IR universals in which that now
and here and I which I mean do not have
a continuing being or are not thus we
reach the stage where we have to posit
the whole of sense certainty itself as
its essence and no longer only one of
its moments has happened in the two
cases where first the object confronting
the eye and then the I was supposed to
be in reality thus in his only sense
certainty as a whole which stands firm
within itself as immediacy and by doing
so excludes from itself all the
opposition which has hitherto obtained
the movement that we're charting out in
section 103 might appear to just be
bringing us full circle but asel
suggests especially as we move into 104
we should probably think of this rather
as something more like a spiral or a
cycloid rather than as a mere circle a
vicious circle where nothing has
actually been achieved or retained where
are we going well let's take a look at
what Hales saying we've been talking a
lot about sense certainty and we want to
know what is the essence of sense
certainty this is the question that we'd
have been asking ourselves the entire
time another way of expressing this is
what is the truth of sense certainty and
we've made a number of transitions we
started out by talking about the object
and we realized that no the essence of
censer and he does not lie in the object
and then we eventually came to with just
a last few few paragraphs talking about
it in terms of the eye the subject the
one who is actually knowing who's who's
who's doing some sort of agency who's
doing the perceiving again that gets
negated as well that is not the essence
of such that certainty either in part
because there can be multiple eyes and
there's a little bit of reflexivity
built in here as well so we're left with
the question then what is the essence of
certainty now to answer that that's why
the rest of this diagram is here we need
to think about what is going on with the
eye and the object so he says the
immediacy of censor is neither an
immediacy of the one nor the other for
in both something mediated is happening
it's actually split into two parts on
the one hand the object reveals itself
to us as a universal as having it now as
having a tear as beating what those are
it also gives us a kind of specificity
so that now can be day and the here can
be a tree or it could be a car or it
could be
an ocean of chalk or whatever you like
right but the the object is in fact a
universal of some sort likewise the eye
is also a universal and it's doing
something different than the object is
the object is giving itself the eye is
what is intending or grasping the object
so what we have going on it says these
are universals in which that now and
here and I which I mean because each of
these actually is not just a universal
pertaining to many particulars but
something to determine it and what I
mean in perceiving it what it is that I
intend in grasping the object the object
as it presents itself to me is something
particular something that I can mean but
then that's something that is vanishing
it's something that I'm not able to
express something I can't articulate
fully in language because language deals
with the universals right so he says the
now that here and yet also the eye
there's a reflexive relation going on
here that's not happening on the side of
the object but it's happening on the
side of the subject these are all
revealed as not having a continuing
being as vanishing so he says they are
not so we reach the stage where we have
to posit the whole of sense certainty he
has at essence and no longer only one of
its moments no longer just the eye or
just the object instead the essence of
set certainly if we want to erase this
circle here is the whole darn thing
that's what the essence is the essence
is the whole the entire all of these
things together now there's something
really interesting going on here because
he says this is presenting itself as in
me
see he says only since certain day as a
whole which stands firm within itself as
immediacy and by so doing excludes from
itself all the opposition which is
hitherto obtained is what we're looking
for so what have we done we've actually
like want all these things back in
together and we have what looks like
immediacy and what angle is at this
point asserting to be in fact immediacy
and we'll have to see whether that
continues on but it is the entirety the
whole not just one of the individual
moments that we could isolate out that's
what's really going on and scent
certainty
this pure immediacy therefore no longer
has any concern with the other nests of
the year as a tree which passes over to
here that is not a tree or with the
other nests of them now as David changes
it to now that is not that is night or
with another eye for which something
else is object its truth preserves
itself as a relation that remains self
identify and which makes no distinction
of what is essential and what is
unattentive
between the eye and its and the object a
relation therefore into which no
distinction
whatever can penetrate I this I assert
then that the heater as a tree and do
not turn around so that the here would
become for me not a free also I take no
notice of the fact that another eye sees
the here as not a tree or that I myself
at another time to take the here as not
tree that now is not day on the contrary
I am a pure act of intuitive I for my
part stick to the fact that the now is
day or that the here is a tree also I do
not compare here and now themselves with
one another but stick firmly to one
immediate relation then now is day
so as I mentioned just earlier with
section 103 in section 104 we're seeing
what seems to be at first glance just
coming back to our starting point having
gone in one big circle and you might say
well perhaps it's a vicious circle or
perhaps we didn't really get any where
we left home and we came back and came
in and everything is exactly as it was
at Hegel almost gives you that
impression in this section that's going
to be changed a little bit as we move
into 105 106 107 as you'll see but it's
important to linger with this now I do
want to suggest to you that instead of
seeing it as a circle you should look at
it as something more like a spiraling in
getting closer and closer to the heart
of things or you could look at it as
spiraling out and incorporating more and
more so what have we found cent
certainty to consist in he said it's
pure immediacy and you notice that we
began with it as pure immediacy and now
we've come back to it as pure immediacy
so what implications does that have well
we've we've learned that it's not
concerned with the other nests of all
sorts of things and what are those
things the here the now the I why is it
not concerned with those because in
immediacy it can't focus on the fact
that these actually do contain other
nests within them they have mediation as
we've seen as we've gone through that
here is a universal now is universal
even I as a universal even though it's
this I this particular I or the
particular I who was writing and Hegel's
book at the time notice there's already
a splitting there who is carrying this
out or as you're following along for the
ride you're the I so he says that this
pure immediacy is no longer concerned
with the other nests of the here is a
tree which passes over into here that is
not a true that's what he means by the
other nests or were the other nosov a
day the now is a day which changes into
a now that is night or for the I who can
be you as I or I as I
or we can have multiple objects so where
does this leave us are we back in the
pure moment of perception in something
that truly is unmediated pure immediacy
well let's follow this out
how does he he sketch us out he says
it's truth preserves itself as a
relation that remains self identical so
there there is a relation there right
but it's a self identical relation which
means that it's the same as itself that
what's on one side is the same as what's
on the other side so this is an
overcoming in a sense of the distinction
between the essential and the
non-essential they're both there they're
both part of it and you know they put
the end in capital because that's really
what he's stressing here or the I and
it's object they turn out to be in some
respect at least at this point in time
at this point in the development they
turn out to be identical to each other
or they're made identical to each other
now how does this actually work here's
where we start to get to some of the
cracks in the foundation is this that we
want to use that kind of metaphor he
says we're not making any distinction
between what's essential and what's in
essential between the eye and the object
a relation in two therefore into which
no distinction whatsoever
can penetrate so we're saying these are
not even really distinctions and we're
not going to look at anything else so
what are we here he says well you know
in this case we have the eye and we have
the tree
there's our this are here and it's day
and it's in a pure immediacy that
doesn't let anything else in how does
this work he says I this I here's the
key term assert that the here is a tree
and I don't turn around so that the here
would become for me not a tree so I
don't look at anything else
I've maintained myself in that posture
of just looking at the tree and saying
that's all there is what else he says I
take no notice of the fact that for that
another eye sees the here and I was not
trade so I was blanking out other people
as well or that I myself at another time
take the here is not true I'm ignoring
that part of myself as well the now is
not day on the contrary I'm a pure act
of intuiting I stick to the fact that
the now is day or that the here is tree
I also don't compare here and now
themselves with one another but stick
firmly to one immediate relation than
now is day so what's going on here it
takes a certain kind of choosing or
activity or persistence or you might
even say stubbornness to bring this off
and how long can one keep doing this
feasibly what's a good question is it
possible to maintain oneself with such
powers of concentration that everything
remains in that immediate moment or is
this a somewhat ilusory state that we
can't truly hold on to that's what we're
going to look at next
since then this certainty will no longer
come forth to us when we direct its
attention to a now that is night or to
an I to whom it is night we will
approach it and let ourselves point to
the now that is asserted we must let
ourselves point to it for the truth of
this immediate relation it is the truth
of this eye which confines itself to one
now or one here were we to examine those
truths afterwards or stand in a distance
from it it would lose its significance
entirely for that would do away with the
immediacy which is essential to it we
must therefore enter the same point of
time or space point them out to
ourselves that is make ourselves into
the same singular eye which is the one
who knows with certainty let us then see
how that immediate is constituted that
is pointed out to us
in section 105 we're starting to see
some of the problems with trying to
maintain ourselves in this restored pure
immediacy one of the problems that's
going to come up is the fact that it
actually does take some sort of effort
as we've seen so let's take a look at
how that that plays out Hickel says that
the certainty will no longer come forth
to us when we direct its attention to
and now that is night or two an eye to
whom it's night so what are we talking
about here in the previous section we've
been talking about the eye which is
looking at a tree and which is taking in
the fact that it's day as now and that
is the truth that is the immediacy for
that eye so long as that moment can be
extended out so long as it can last and
they can't keep doing that though
because we can also have an eye we do
have an eye for which it's now night and
the question is is that I really the
same thing as this eye so he says you
know we have an eye to whom is now night
and so we have to approach it and let
ourselves point to them now that's being
asserted we must let ourselves point to
it so when we're engaged in Sandton
certainty we're already seeing that's
again not a pure passive immediacy
receptivity there's already a pointing
going on a focusing of attention and
it's being done by the eye that's that's
maintaining itself in this posture in
this this moment in this comportment we
can say this directionality towards the
object or is the meaning that it's
intending so he says we must let
ourselves point to the truth of this
immediate relation is in the truth of
the eye which confines itself to one now
or one here so that's where the truth
that we're going to keep is going to
reside and it's going to remain true so
the line is we can keep doing that but
you remember that just a few passages
ago we saw that that truth of whatever
it is whatever content we have over here
can become stale and how did it become
stale by something else coming in as the
possibility for what is now whereas what
now is now at this point so he says
we're we to examine this truth
afterwards or to stand at a distance
from it we would lose its significance
entirely that would do away with the
immediacy which is essential to it so
what do we have to do we have to as he
says enter into that same space and time
in order to do that in order to preserve
it in order to have the truth in order
to possess that certainty but is this
really possible for us not only do we
have a shift between say this eye and
this eye you know if we exist over time
we're a whole sequence of eyes not just
this one that happens to be here at this
point in time it would be sort of you
know if we want to do any kind of
extended metaphor for this imagine that
in these videos I was always wearing
exactly the same outfit
so same tie same shirt same jacket and
you know we won't mock your wrath
lighting is stays the same all of that
sort of stuff keep the sound levels the
same would that be kind of a kind of
strange you know would that would that
keep things in that present moment it
would give you the illusion of staying
in that present moment it would give you
a kind of illusion of continuity
wouldn't it and I suppose if I you know
going back you know let's say I get to
video 300 of this series and I say
you know I want to be back it we're in
the same stuff as I was in sense
certainty and you know forget the fact
that I've already worn two different
outfits because I had different times
for this I'll put on this jacket and
this tie and this shirt and tie my hair
back in exactly the same ways I better
know how to changed my glasses or
anything so that I can come back to
exactly this the same moment would that
really work is that is that truly
possible can you regain that lost
certainty that lost truth of something
that is bound by temporal and spatial
coordinates
it's hard enough even just to put the
camera and that's tripod in the same
place every time that I shoot let alone
to come back to the same content every
time so Hegel goes on and he says you
know if we're going to examine this
truth then it would lose its its its
significance so we we would have to
enter into the same point of space or
time point them out to ourselves make
ourselves into the same singular I who
is the one who knows with certainty so
then he says well let's see if we can
actually do this how can we become that
I